Kim Kardashian sets the record straight
on her newborns name I mean hello and
serves Lamar Odom with the ultimate clap
back for people to just think that's
okay
is so frustrating lately I haven't had a
big mouth he'd be really proud its 2018
and Kim Kardashian is taking no
prisoners especially when it comes to
her family when I had no idea that I was
gonna end up feeling this way Kim came
to her sister Khloe's defense after her
ex-husband Lamar Odom told BET's mancave
this I understand was over his old when
she was with her second or third NBA
ball player yeah that didn't sit well
with the mama of three she simply
tweeted in response quote or second or
third brothel so weird but it wasn't all
shaved Lamar also sent Khloe well wishes
as she prepares to welcome her first
child with her man Tristan Thompson
I'm happy for me meanwhile Kim and hubby
Kanye West have yet to reveal the name
of their new baby girls though many fans
thought this Louis Vuitton monogrammed
Kim post it was a clue but Kim says
that's not the case she clarified on
Twitter it was simply a nod to Kim Jones
the brand's artistic director who
recently left the company perfect
you